[Music]
earlier this week I did something
unusual is allenge to our viewers okay
and this is my challenge I said if you
can find any mistakes or errors on our
show send us a video telling us about it
confront me with this mistake and let's
see if it really was a mistake
so far I've crushed all critics with
powerful replying to Charlie Sheen with
powerful rebuttals I've crushed them
they're all trolls so far I have crushed
all critics and I tell you something and
I've done it with very strong arguments
today I understand we have yet another
Challenger so let's play it hi Coco this
is Nicole last night I was watching your
show and you did a skit with the machete
guy and there was this drink um tying
her blood yeah here's a picture that
looks like fruit punch you wouldn't be
able to like see right through it so
yeah that was like a huge error um you
should really like fix that in the
future
[Applause]
huge error here the way she talked to me
I know it's ridiculous it's insane
question the master a will I have
definitive proof that there was real
tiger blood in that bottle
here's the man that procured that tiger
blood our prop master bill tall all
right so so bill what you have to say
hey Nicole this is this is not produce
it's real Tigers blood I got it from
this guy right here very good bill now
tell Nicole why the tiger is standing up
rigid attached to a base rigor mortis
bill tell everybody thank you bill looks
like I'm three for three but the
challenge still stands if you think
you've spotted an error on our show
report it at team koco.com
slash haha I found an error and sent us
a link to your video explanation and
let's see if you've got what it takes to
make chunk meat out of the master very
nice little break
[Applause]